dr. sleep brings Stephen King's novel to
the screen in a way that both honors the
author's original version of The Shining
and manages to reconcile it with Stanley
Kubrick's vision the result is a film
that's a sequel to two stories at once
with its own mythology and a
multi-layered ending Abra spends much of
the film getting to know the extent of
her own strength with the shining and
it's clear that she's quite pleased with
the things she can do during their final
encounter at the Overlook Hotel Rose
tells Abra that she reminds her of her
younger self because there's a darkness
and a burr that hasn't reached its full
potential yet will the darkness start to
take her over as she ages or will she be
able to handle it as we see from the
look on her face in the final shot the
film leaves it an open question one of
the earliest scenes in dr. sleep
establishes that even after he and his
mother escaped the Overlook young Danny
Torrance was haunted by the ghosts who
attacked him there they followed him
from the hotel to his home in Florida
and attempted to feed on him until dick
hallorann taught young Danny a trick
that would allow him to lock the ghosts
away in boxes dan has kept the over
Lagos locked away in his own mind for
years but finally unleashes them on Rose
the Hat the film's final scene makes it
clear that while the Overlook is gone
the ghosts are not the woman from room
237 has returned to haunt a burr stones
bathroom trying to feed on her shine now
that she can't feed on Dan's
Abra clearly knows how to deal with the
woman thanks to Dan's mentorship but
what about the rest of the Overlook
ghosts when Dan and Abra meet in person
for the first time Dan explains that a
lot of people have a little bit of a
shine but he's only met a handful in his
life who knew how to use it
Abra is one of those people of course
and so is dick hallorann Brad Trevor the
baseball boy Abra has a vision of just
before he dies is another with an
uncanny gift that he is only just
beginning to understand when he's killed
by the true not the film makes it very
clear that APRA's our filet is the
reason the true knot is defeated because
she was able to figure out who and what
they were in a way that no one else
could now that she's defeated the knot
she probably won't stop using her power
for good though there's darkness in her
there's also tremendous light it's easy
to imagine her using her mighty gift to
track down others
Shyne particularly children and make
sure they're safe from the places and
things that want to eat what shines as
dr. sleep begins the true knot is
introduced as a close knit small group
of psychic vampires who roam the country
under the radar and find themselves
slowly running out of the life-force
they call steam by the end only rows the
Hat is left and at a confrontation at
the Overlook Dan taunts her by
proclaiming her to be the last one
standing
Rose responds that she's not actually
the last one it may have been an empty
boast designed to scare Dan but what if
Rose is right about people like her are
there still other knots out there in
this world roaming the landscape in
search of steam are there more places
like the Overlook that will eat what
shines are there would be knots that are
only just beginning to learn how to
consume steam coming together in new
ways or importantly will people like
that be able to stay alive in a world
where steam is harder to come by a bur
stone will probably find out one day in
Stanley Kubrick's The Shining we learn
very early on that the Overlook Hotel
was built atop a Native American burial
ground which sets the stage for a legacy
of violence that carries on throughout
the hotel's history the site is supposed
to be located on an Indian burial ground
and I believe they actually had to
repeal a few Andina taxes they were
building it in Stephen King's original
novel the Overlook burns down at the end
of the story but the shining film leaves
it standing seemingly waiting for the
next caretakers the hotel finally burns
to the ground at the end of dr. sleep
but the ghosts don't die with it at
least some of them are still present
trying to follow a bura instead of Dan
with that in mind what happens to the
sight of the Overlook itself
what will the owners of the land do with
it now that the rotted old hotel is gone
will it be preserved as a Heritage Site
in an effort to calm down the negative
energy there will the peace be
maintained Dan Torrance is well aware of
the imprint his father made on him he
was so traumatized by what happened at
the Overlook that he didn't talk for
some time afterward and he ultimately
took up his father's alcoholic habits
later in life
the contrast between Dan and his
father's memory comes to a head and one
of the most stirring scenes in the film
when he meets the ghost of his father
now Lloyd the bartender in the Gold Room
at the ruined Overlook
have a direct confrontation over a glass
of whiskey that Dan refuses to drink
while his father's ghost fumes over the
life he claims his family stole from him
with the Overlook gone is Jack Torrance
able to find peace he does find a
version of it and dr. sleep the novel
but the film leaves that question open
was he beyond saving or did Dan free his
father by burning the hotel check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one